je n'ai jamais demandé à quelqu'un de me
donner son vin ne fait absolument pas et
heureusement boussès demande non ça ne
demande pas le manque pas de le voler
[Musique]
je m'appelle table gold rg 30 chez plus
tard on recommence alors
je m'appelle fameux bol d'air j'ai 36
ans et il ya deux ans de cela j'ai donné
un rat à la vie à ma bonne décision
jusqu'au la 7 mai deux ans qui est
toujours en vie et lui plus qu'avant
donc c'est très bien
je connais leurs cannes depuis quelques
années déjà et il était malade depuis
déjà quelques temps et en fait il est
ici mon listes d'attentes pour recevoir
un rein mais malheureusement et avait
personne qui se décidait à mourir avec
le bon grain
à dix c'est un rare officiel en dehors
du corps pour filtrer 900 on met une
aiguille dans une veine on retire le
sens et pas en une machine on le remet
dans la veine ça c'est vraiment c'est un
filtre je suis rentré en d'y aller on va
dîner moyenne de 3 ans et demi pour être
greffés
quand j'ai passé ces trois ans et demi
j'en ai marre
de passer
on s'est foutu de moi c'est normal c'est
moyenne donc c'est lui qui dépérissait
de plus en plus ma mère a une leucémie
donc j'avais déjà donné la moelle donc
le don d'organes mais le don c'était
quelque chose d'assez familier et b en
fait ça me semblait une évidence mois
sachant que je pouvais y faire quelque
chose je n'aurais pas supporté qu'il lui
arrive quelque chose et que je n'ai rien
faire
[Musique]
donc j'ai proposé à leurs cannes si si
ça l'intéressait au début le thé pas
trop enfin déguisé non enfin parce que
c'est quand même sens des
responsabilités pour pour les deux
évidemment c'était un matin très tôt on
devait aller à liège enregistré je pense
qu'il des gens vraiment c'est quand vous
prenez les trains la en hiver vers 6h30
il fait tout noir et ça pique dans les
yeux et est à ce moment là je lui dis je
lui ai dit que voilà moi j'étais prêt
oui il m'a un peu surpris un tableau
n'est pas quelqu'un d'extrêmement
sérieux ya plutôt tendance à faire des
blagues et là il va y ait une fois
ça m'a un peu surpris de ta peau mal à
l'aise jamais demander à quelqu'un de me
donner 120 ça me fait absolument pas et
heureusement ne cesse de mon nom ça se
demande pas le mantois
c'est pas la première personne qui m'a
proposé de me donner son nom comme moi
comme d'hab j'ai dit oui ouvert
bon on me l'a proposé dans plein de
circonstances différentes aussi à 2
heures du matin soirée et donc voilà et
puis là c'était un peu plus sérieux mais
quand même de toute façon moi j'ai
jamais demandé à quelqu'un a fait
pleinement ma pablo la différence est
que après il est revenu avec saïda
réfléchi et puis un gros truc à changer
se trouvait par rapport aux autres
personnes sais c'est qu'il a pris des
renseignements
il faudrait prendre un bloc
party
ted et un tirage à pour supporter pour
que le corps est simplement
cela c'est la plus grosse règles à
respecter
si on passait mais évidemment on peut le
perdre assez rapidement
parce que le corps en fait ils
n'acceptent pas un corps étranger il
pense que le rein servirait donc quand
j'ai décidé de donner un rein
il ya déjà un
parcours personnel il ya toute une
batterie de tests qui dure plus ou moins
une demi année quand même un une
batterie de tests physiques
donc moi j'étais
convaincu à la base que il y avait
qui avait pas de risque en fait mais par
exemple dans ma famille j'ai vu qu'elle
était les réactions ci dut ou tu as fait
avec de reims c'est qu'il ya une raison
c'est elle à la blague seul à la réponse
que j'avais le plus souvent et puis
quand même l'idée de mettre quelqu'un de
sain sur une table d'opération
l'endormir l'ouvrir et lui retirer un
organe ça fait bizarre
ça fait bizarre et beaucoup de gens
c'est plus par peur je pense que les
gens ne le font pas même moi j'ai été
pris de crises d'angoissé de trois jours
avant l'opération typiquement la
dernière fois que j'ai eu mon fils dans
les bras j'ai pleuré parce que je
savais pas vers quoi j'allais je ne
savais pas si j'allais me réveiller de
l'opération parce qu'on sait jamais même
les docteurs vous dis c'est une
opération leur héros n'existent pas on
peut très bien vivre avec seulement 1
faut juste faire gaffe parce qu'au bar
ou non à castle donc s'il se casse on
n'a pas de back up voilà mais le minage
les mis en lieu sûr et donc si le lien
se casse devrait reprendre le marché
local sas et voilà c'est avec les murs
lieu sur
la mairie ou non ça change quand la
relation où on est clairement plus
proche qu'on profite de nouvelles quand
même on s'appelle plus
parce que sinon je pense que c'est aussi
parce qu'on va passer
quinze jours à l'hôpital on sort ça crée
des liens non
vous ne passez pas par certaines
douleureuse exemple donc voilà c'est un
peu le parcours du combattant qu'on a
fait ensemble qui nous a rapprochés plus
que le don je pense réellement moi je
pense pas le matin quand je me lève à
pavot madonna vraiment pas j'ai juste
gagné qu'une fois par an le même vite au
resto
le trompe 30 juin vite au resto pour
l'anniversaire alors nous on se fait des
vannes entre nous
même moi quand j'en fais trop je me dis
des foi arrêtent de parler de ça parce
que ça n'a pas définir la personne qu'on
aime ce serait malsain de se mettre dans
un truc de je t'ai donné ta pris fin ou
non non on reste amis on l'a fait parce
qu'on est amis et voilà on en reste là
tu y en avait un sentiment de n'être
redevable vraiment envers la personne en
fait les psychologues interdirait le la
greffe ils font très attention à ça en
amont ils font attention y'a pas une
pression d'un côté et une culpabilité de
l'autre et ça c'est très très important
je pense que c'est primordial quand je
vois leurs quelques mois il va mieux oui
bien sûr on peut que l'encourager après
j'ai pas dû me convaincre de faire ça je
sais pas je le sentais comme ça je les
fais un point c'est tout
[Musique]